hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from round seven of
this year's London chess classic it just
finished and uh it's uh quite a quite an
amazing game if if you run it through an
engine it will say that it is perhaps
not the most precise game by either
player but it is definitely a most
interesting one if there was a an engine
that um evaluated chess moves by how
interesting they are this game would
score I believe close to 100% now let's
check it out Hans Neiman versus polish
grandmas m Bartel uh you guys will have
a really awesome pause the video moment
in this one let's check it out so niman
has the white pieces and he opens with
E4 we have E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to C4 Hans goes for the Joo
piano the Italian game Knight to F6 and
now D3 uh switching to the modern
Bishop's opening of the two knights
defense with have H6 and now Pawn to C3
we have D6 Pawn to A4 and now Pawn to G6
uh we have Pawn to A5 grab having more
space on the queen side and pawn to A6
we have castles and Bishop to G7 Knight
B to D2 and now we have castles here uh
Rook to E1 and Knight to H7 with the
idea of moving the king and advancing
that pawn to F5 at some point also you
do get more control over that G5 Square
so here we have Queen to B3 putting
pressure on this F7 Pawn so you can't
play King to h8 as the F7 Pawn would
fall H but interestingly this is the
amazing part that's exactly what
happened M played King to h8 and he
offers the F7 Pawn now the question is
should you capture this Pawn well our
good friend the engine says that yes
most definitely it is the best move it's
a free Pawn so we should capture it and
that is what Hans plays he plays Bishop
captures on F7 Queen to F6 now
threatening the bishop and also gaining
nice control over the f file and Bishop
back to C4 we have Pawn to G5 now M
wants to play G4 kick away the Knight
and capture on F2 and hopefully very
quickly check made the white king so you
have to prevent this Rook to E2 now the
Knight can move D F2 Pawn is defended
and pawn to G4 we have Knight back to E1
and now Pawn to H5 so okay you give up a
pawn but you are getting a huge
Initiative for it we have Knight to F1
the Knight the knights are already here
to stop the advancement of the black
pawns Pawn to H4 we have Queen back to
D1 H the queen also wants to help out
with the defense and now Knight to E7
preparing to bring this Knight into the
attack as well uh we have Queen to D2 or
trying to get the queen uh control over
those dark squares so now for example
Knight G5 is impossible as the queen and
Bishop control it and Here pawn to C6
grabbing more space um in the center
also you will have support for D5 in the
future if needed uh we have Pawn to G3
and now Pawn to D5 right away so just um
uh like a game you would see maybe in
1854 like it's that kind of a game so
Bishop back to B3 and now Bishop to to
E6 okay just developing preparing to get
the Rook into the game the bishop will
be very useful on this diagonal Knight
to G2 putting pressure on the pawn here
and Knight to G6 defending with have e
captures on D5 C captures and now Hans
has to decide how to go about it now the
uh most objectively precise way to play
is Knight captures on H4 and it looks
weird you allow black to mess up your
Pawn structure but after Queen captures
on H4 and queen to E1 there's really not
all that much black can play once the
Knight Blends on G3 that's pretty much
it black does not have a way of um uh
forcing anything here and black opened
up his King considerably as well however
Hans played Pawn to D4 instead we have
Pawn to E4 closing up the position and
making the bishop on B3 not so useful a
piece uh and now Rook to A4 hunt wants
to get that C4 move up the board we have
Pawn to H3 and Knight back to E1 and hun
is very happy with his position here
because the pawns although uh they are
very far advant Advanced aren't really
doing any damage here it's merely a
double shield towards the white king so
you know if you if you're opening up
this position you have to sacrifice
something so Queen back to F7 now Rook
to B4 putting pressure on the B7 pawn
and now Rook eight to C8 we have Bishop
to C2 uh uh putting the bishop on this
diagonal and now Bishop to F6 uh gaining
more control over G5 and H4 also you
will be able to harass The Rook with let
a bishop D7 uh Queen D1 and now we have
Bishop to d8 Shifting the bishop over to
this diagonal to be used to attack the
the the white king but also just putting
pressure on that A5 Pawn so here we have
Bishop to H6 attacking The Rook on f8
and Rook to G8 we have Bishop um uh
sorry Pawn to C4 uh trying to open up
the position and uh there's really not
all that much you can do like Bishop
captures on A5 is nice okay but then you
attack the bishop with Rook to A4 the
bishop will move and then you capture on
D5 uh completely opening up the position
you will capture on e4 and you will get
the past D Pawn whereas Black's attack
simply is not happening but instead
Bishop to G5 was played saying okay
let's just trade here hun said all right
let's do it Bishop captures Knight
captures and now Knight to E3 uh putting
just more pressure on D5 hunts knows
that once this happens either C captures
or captures here and then D5 that his
position will be just winning and here
we have Knight to H4 this is uh m
realizes that uh you know situation on
the queen side and in the centry is not
going his way so he has to look for his
chances on the king side okay H accepts
the the sacrifice G captures an H4
Knight to F3 with check and now King to
H1 this is the the absolute best way to
do it of course capturing the Knight H
would not be all that impressive after G
captures on F3 as it comes with a check
from the rook and once you move the king
then you lose the Rook as well and uh
well the the entire position opens up
for the black pieces to attack the white
king
however after King to H1 Hun's King is
remarkably safe here Knight captures an
H2 was played and now C captures on D5
ignoring the Knight here and okay G3 uh
we have D captures on E6 and now G2 with
check like I said like was played in
1854 uh we have Knight three captures on
G2 H captures and G2 and now not
capturing the Knight of course because
then you just get checkmated G1 queen
king H3 and queen captures on H uh on E6
for example will be Checkmate so King to
G1 was played and now Queen to F4 trying
to get the Knight to G4 and then to
Checkmate the white king and hun says
all right let's go Rook captures on e4
attacking the queen but now you have to
go for it Queen captures on F2 you
either sacrifice the queen here or you
resign the game uh but the queen
sacrific is only a temporary one as you
will be getting another one so King
capus G1 uh bringing a queen into the
game with check King E2 and now Knight
to f F1 uh preparing something although
there isn't all that much you can do
here Hunt is uh in fact objectively
completely winning here but if that was
the case uh this would not be as
interesting a game so Queen to C1 was
played hunt wants to play Queen to H6
Checkmate deliver mate in one and now
comes Rook to G2 with check checking the
white king and nicely connecting with
the bishop on C2 and look at this King
to D1 Rook C captures on C2 and this is
where the magic happens what do you play
here in this position uh hans's position
is completely winning and uh to to be
frank with you there's more than one
winning move here many moves are
completely winning for hunts here so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for hunts while I give you a couple
of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and going
either for Queen to H6 with check or E7
uh as those are two two of the very
winning ideas and for those of you who
played Queen captures and C2 the move
that Hans played that move will not be
winning you the game so just to give you
an example if you play Queen to H6 check
King to G8 and now E7 there's not all
that much black can do you can give um
uh maybe one check but it's not all that
impressive Rook G to D2 check Queen will
have to capture sure but it's not a
problem let's say Rook captures on D2
King to C1 and there there's no
continuation here uh this Pawn will just
Queen and that's it there there's no way
for you to even complicate things here
whatever you play here just Pawn
promotes to a queen and that's it it's
Unstoppable and uh there aren't any
useful checks there's really nothing you
can do here so Queen to H6 in that
position uh really uh the the way to go
and even the reason hunt put the queen
on this diagonal uh the other move you
could play is E7 right away you could
even sacrifice the queen on C1 and after
Rook captures you could play King
captures again not much for black to do
black will have to stop the pawn with
something like Rook to G8 then you will
bring a Queen into the game and after
Rook captures Rook captures with check
King to G7 uh now Rook captures and B7
with check and you have too much
material uh for uh for the queen king to
F6 you will play Knight to F3 attack the
queen and then slowly uh improve your
position and get those uh Pawns of the
board or even just win tactically so
those were the two options available to
Hunts this one a bit more uh calculating
required but Queen to H6 just wins on
the spot however hunt played Queen
captures on C2 I imagine under the
impression that absolutely everything is
winning here but um uh even though it's
similar to the position that we just
discussed this this move also blunders a
piece so Rook captures on C2 Knight
captures on C2 and now the move that
hunts missed is Knight to E3 the double
check very strange uh to to miss a move
like that and it wasn't even in time
trouble hunt had like
20 uh let me just check uh sorry uh when
Queen captures on C2 was played yeah he
had 31 uh 32 minutes on the clock so
uh not really an issue but yeah here you
will lose material because now after
King to D2 uh Queen to F2 check probably
the move that he missed King to D3 and
now just Knight captures and C2 and you
cannot take the knight uh and there's uh
really not all that much uh uh you you
can do like if you if you play Rook
captures on B7 Queen F3 check and you
can't you can't do anything if you take
the Knight H then Queen captures Rook
with check also picks up the other Rook
you also cannot block with the Rook
because the square is covered so that's
a huge problem for Hans so Hans said all
right I'm not even going to move the
Knight I'm not going to uh move the Rook
I'm going to advance the pawn to D5 and
this is where things really have gone
wrong with Rook captures on B7 still
possible although like I said it's bad
but it's still possible to continue with
with Queen to F3 check King to D2 and
queen captures on e4 E7 and you you're
still fighting for the draw although not
not the greatest of possessions but
after Pawn to D5 uh now he's already
already entering losing territory Knight
captures on B4 comes with check Rook
captures on B4 and now Queen to C5 so
okay he still has the rook and he still
still has the two connected pass pawns
he has the outside pass H Pawn uh but uh
uh it's simply not possible to win this
If U MOS plays it precisely so here
let's see what happened Rook to D4 of
course Hans wants to start pushing that
pawn so of course you blockate it Queen
to D6 we have King to E4 King to G7 it's
important to bring the king here to help
out with the advance with with the
stopping of the advancement of the white
pawns so the black queen can become
active start checking the white king and
first pick off the weaknesses of the
position uh before advancing these pawns
because a queen alone will not be able
to beat the rook and the two connected
pass pawns so Rook D3 uh we have Queen
to H2 now just going after the
weaknesses here Rook to
C3 uh and now Queen captures on H4 with
check there's no stopping that King F5
Queen to H5 with check King to E4 and
now Queen to H4 with check King F5 and
now Queen to H2 of course not agreeing
to a repetition King to E4 King to G6
now we have Rook to C8 and now Queen to
D6 again it's best to just stop those
pawns right where they are uh Rook back
to C2 and now Queen back to G3 Rook back
to C8 King to G7 and now King to D4 uh
we have Queen to F4 with check King to
D3 and now Queen to D6 going after the
pawn here so King to C 4 and now King to
F6 we have Rook to h8 uh Queen to C7
with check we have King to D4 and now
Queen to G7 attacking The Rook not
allowing any checks from behind Rook to
H1 and now King to E7 with check nicely
blockading the position here King to C5
uh and now Queen to G6 was played here
Queen to G3 would be a pretty bad move
even though it looks like you're going
after the white king from behind H but
Rook to H7 would ensure Hansa draw so
it's best um uh keep it clean Queen to
G6 now just going after Queen to C2
check which will pick off the B2 pawn
and that's pretty much it if you go for
B4 then Queen to E4 will attack the rook
and the B4 pawn and also guard H7 so
even that is impossible for white even
though B4 is winning in in most uh
positions for white uh but yeah here
Rook to C1 stopping Queen to C2 check
now Queen to D3 again whatever you play
you're you're going to connect with
something here Queen B5 check will just
pick up the Pawn so Rook to C4 was
played but now Queen to E3 check and now
if you go King to B4 doesn't really help
you Queen to D2 check will connect with
the B2 pawn and with the D5 Pawn so you
will start losing material so hun tried
Rook to D4 uh and here Queen to C1 check
finally picks off the B2 pawn and once
the B Pawn leaves the board you know
that it really is over Rook to C4 Queen
captures on B2 Rook e four hoping for
something but uh it's not happening you
you you you're not hoping to advance D6
as the E6 Pawn is defended but Queen B5
check King D4 Queen captures on A5
stopping all of Hunt's hopes and the
dreams uh King to uh sorry uh King to E5
now comes Queen to C7 with check and he
was in this position un move 74 or maybe
even in this position on move 75 that
hunt Neeman resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here there's
no move and now black can simply start
advancing the pawns and it's a game over
there there is no way for you to ever
push this Pawn with the king and queen
and controlling the square uh so it's uh
you know resigns time so it's a very
very strange situation where hunt was um
uh better for pretty much uh the entire
game uh and then once this Rook captures
and C2 move landed and Hunt had 33
minutes on the clock uh uh he had two
winning ideas Queen to H6 a winning idea
E7 a winning idea uh and also the move
that he played Queen captures on C2 the
position is a draw but um I I guess he
was so uh you know uh furious with
himself for for blundering such a
winning position that he ended up losing
it which is something that okay happens
to everyone and obviously it can also
happen on the on the top level uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it big congratulations to M for
executing hunts like this with the black
pieces I mean this is truly like an
attacking game that uh we' see in in a
book you know really like something
morphe would play or Anderson would play
or you know some of the older Masters
sacrifice the F Pawn push H5 G5 H4 you
know blockade the position on the king
side and then sacrifice for the attack
against the the white king then a
temporary Queen sacrifice then I
mean uh crazy stuff yeah uh beautiful
game it it seems that it was too much
for Hans to handle and Matos emerges
Victorious uh so once again hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to wish a
very happy birthday to bushan barade and
I would like to thank David gasparian
Rik schaer Albert vardell and Nathan I
love you Dad for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and remember whenever you
have more than one winning option uh
makes make sure you still choose the the
winning one uh see you soon